I was born to rule the seven kingdoms, and I will.
Cersei will be ready
Hey, YouTubers new game of thrones coming tonight, so we need to talk about Jon snow and dragons
We've been saying winter is coming for so many seasons, now we should really say fan services coming
Jon Snow daenerys meeting tonight for the first time jon. Snow doesn't have ghosts with him
Which is a whole other thing I'll link that video at the end of this, but as we know that jon
snow is at dragon stone regardless of what your interpretation of the prophecy of the prince who was promised was he's
critical to it, the new idea
is that people shouldn't be quite as
specific with it if they have been in the past like the prince was promised is no one person there are promise people and there's
the three heads of the dragon
Which is also part of the prince who was promised.
So when people first read that in the books they thought that meant there were three promised Dragon riders
There are a number of hopefuls in the books and as the TV show has slowly changed things from that and now we have
Melisandre saying prophecy is a tricky thing
Maybe we should be careful about how we interpret that the idea that everybody has interpreted every vision
Everything wrong on the TV show even bran hasn't got everything a hundred percent
But there's this theory that jon snow being half targaryen being part of this huge prophecy being so critical to the story is
One of the Dragon Riders which dragon should he ride and how long before the show pays that off?
It's only just revealed jon. Snow's true heritage, and it hasn't even
Officially on-screen confirmed that he's half targaryen, even though
If you've read the books you've read between the lines all the clues the show's given you about Rhaegar targaryen
LyAnna stark you know that his father is rhaegar
So there's this big thing going on in the TV show where they're trying to pay off all these loose threads that they set up
There are a lot of people that think that's even the only reason that they're bringing
Gendry back just so that they don't leave that plot thread hanging and he won't have some larger role to play
But when you talk about Jon snow riding dragons you have to take into consideration
How the Valyrian bonded with their dragons how they tame them so to speak
It's not quite the same thing as taming animals, and then there's the consequences of Jon snow riding a dragon
I don't think there's any way that he rides a dragon this season
I do feel like if they're going to pay that off it won't be till season 8 because think about the way the lords of
The North reacted to jon snow when he merely suggested the idea of them meeting with Daenerys, "a targaryen
Cannot be trusted"
Which is a bit of an eye wink to the fact that John Snow is also part targaryen which means that littlefinger is
Probably doing the calculus right now even if he's not a hundred percent sure that John snow is the son of Rhaegar targaryen
He probably has his suspicions
So this season seems like it's more about bringing John snow to dragons and then leaving what happens next for season eight
Hopefully we can all be in agreement that if jon snow is going to ride a dragon the dragon
The dragon he should ride should be the one that's named for his father
Regal so hopefully regal will survive the season eight and they can pay that off
But typically in the past the way the targaryen past dragons now because they live much longer than humans do is that
Classically they'll start the bonding process between person and dragon when the dragon is still in the egg unhatched
So they'll put dragon eggs in children's beds hoping to form a bond between them
Then you have situations like balerion the black dread a dragon who was hatched in ancient Valyria before the doom he was taken to
Dragonstone when the targaryens escaped with their family most of the stories you hear about them are from Aegon's conquest
Him riding around the seven kingdoms lighting everybody on fire by the time of the conquest
Valyrian was over a hundred years old
meaning that he had multiple riders and for the most part people just assumed that as long as your targaryen you can ride your
Ancestors Dragon, so if aegon the conquerer had children. They'd be able to Ride bully dorian. Just like Bol
Aryans form a rider pass them down to aegon the conquerer, but it's actually not quite so simple
There's a little bit of a clarification during the princess in the queen's story
whereby you find out that even if you're the child or you're part of the bloodline of a dragon rider, you can't just
Automatically hop that dragon and everything will be fine you have to bond with it. The same way that someone like Jon
Snow bonds with ghost it sounds kind of magical and supernatural
But it's actually much more practical like it happens in real life all the time like people
Bond with horses you have to get a horse to trust you before it'll let you ride it
Dragons are just the uber version of that so just because you can ride a horse
Doesn't mean that your child could come along and just hop on the horse
There's even a special
passage in the princess and the queen's story where it implies that someone who was not a targaryen was able to tame a
Dragon called Sheep's dealer
So it reads in the end the brown dragon was brought to heel by the cunning and persistence of a small brown girl
it doesn't really give her name of six and ten named neddy who delivered him a freshly slaughtered sheep every morning until
Sheeps dealer learned to accept and expect her she was black-haired brown-eyed
brown skinned skinny foul-Mouthed filthy and fearless in the
first and last Dragon Rider of the Dragon Sheeps dealer
So it just implies that you can win dragons over given enough time and persistence
You get them to trust you they'll let you ride them in just because you're a targaryen doesn't mean they will
automatically trust you
I
Really love the way it talks about the qualities that girl
The implication being that as long as jon snow shows no fear and gets one of the dragons to trust him somehow
He will be able to ride it whether or not he wants to or whether or not the realm will riot if he does
So hopefully that explains a little bit about how the show is treating the three heads of the dragon prophecy
How jon snow being part targaryen makes it much more likely that
He's able to ride a dragon
But also, how that doesn't necessarily
matter a hundred percent
There are other ways to ride dragons like it would probably take many
Many months to win a dragon over just bringing
It dead sheep every single day
But you can imagine drogon would probably like someone more if they brought him a fresh sheep every single day
But also just to address tyrion Dragon rider. I know a lot of people are thinking tyrion may be part targaryen
Maybe there are some clues and what happened during season six yes, I do think that tyrion should ride a dragon
I do think that they trust him
So I do think that if he tried he'd be able to do it whether or not the show ever tries to pay that off
It seems like this season is more about jon snow coming to Daenerys
So it's choosing more to focus on Jon snow in this grand prophecy sense
But it does feel like they're going to wait til season eight to pay a lot of these big things off because he's only leading
Daenerys for the first time this season
So let me know in the comments who is going to be the first person to ride a dragon besides Daenerys?
Do you think they'll pay that jon snow twist off in season eight and which dragon
Do you want to see him ride?  but what will happen tonight
Is I'll post my episode 3 video after it airs and then I'll post my rick and morty episode 2 video early Monday morning
Then I'll post that game of thrones
Episode 4 trailer video so Rick and Morty is back if you guys didn't know it's going to be on at 11:30 p.m.
Tonight after game of thrones, so I recommend you check it out. If you've never seen it before it's on adult Swim
Congratulations to the latest Giveaway Winner Lewis
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
While you wait for everything click here for the trailer for tonight's episode
And you can click here for brand new Rick and morty. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight.